quand j'avais 18 ans ensuite j'ai
rencontré dans un contexte d'euro l'air
parce que je sais pas pourquoi je
traînais avec des gens qui se déroule à
un garçon américain et on est tombé
amoureux et on a une espèce de relation
épistolaire et après je suis allé le
rejoindre et ça a fait que j'ai voulu
énormément améliorer mon anglais est en
fait ça ça m'a complètement miel le pied
à l'étrier à tout ce qui est devenu
impatient après c'est à dire
le stand-up le scénario une partie de ce
qu'est la télé américaine aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'était une rencontre fortuite et
bizarre et éclair qui s'est soldée par
un week-end à kansas city extrêmement
glauque parce que déjà ce pas une ville
game en plus si tu vas pour te faire
larguer c'est pas drôle mais en revanche
je pense que ça a un peu changé ma vie
puisque voilà ça m'a ouvert un truc que
je la sais pas ils sont mais c'est
surtout pour dire c'est bien d'avoir une
raison autre d'apprendre quelque chose
je pense que tous les parents désespérés
devrait prendre des amants allemands
pour leur enfant d un moment qui a
changé ma vie
c'est l'année où j'ai accepté que je
n'arriverais pas professionnellement à
me faire une voie par les études ou en
boulot normal et que j'ai lâché ce que
je faisais et que j'ai rejoint des
copains qui ouvrait une roulotte et qui
m'ont dit viens vendant des burgers avec
nous je dis ok et en fait ça a libéré un
truc c'est que ne pas faire un boulot
que j'aimais pas la journée ne pas être
enfermé dans un bureau
ça a complètement libéré mon cerveau
créatif qui a fait que j'ai pu écrire en
dehors et en un an
voilà je me mettais à faire des scènes
et puis j'ai écrit les scénarios de tout
ça est donc ce qui était intéressant
c'est que socialement c'était pas très
acceptable ça que ça faisait peur à mes
parents ça faisait pas ma famille ça
faisait peur à tous mais moi ça a été un
sentiment de liberté de dingue de penser
mon travail pas comme ce que je devais
faire pour accéder à un certain statut
mais juste bon ben voila mais j'en ai me
vont je fais un truc que je trouve qu'il
ya un peu de chance ça m'a aidé à
envisager le travail comme peut-être un
espace
de liberté bizarrement c'est à dire que
je sortais d'une logique d'aliénation au
travail de il faut s'accomplir par un
statut il faut atteindre certaines
choses à certains âges mais juste je
paye mon loyer jeu ça me donne un peu
d'autonomie financière et après je peux
développer ce que je veux créativement
etc ça ouvert la voie pour topshop à
partir de 24 25 ans ça s'est enchaîné
très vite mais j'avais une j'ai vu bien
neuf ans de rien du tout en fait d'une
qu'une longue suite sans parachute et je
vois plein de gens sont malheureux dans
des bureaux et qui souhaitent en se
disant qu'il devrait avoir en plus la
volonté et la discipline de faire des
trucs créatifs à côté tout en vrai c'est
dur d'avoir ton cerveau à disponibilité
pour un patron x heures par semaine et
après en plus d'être mobilisés donc
parfois faut se dire allez je vais
vendre des brassées sur la plage on voit
ce qui se passe à côté
[Musique]
un moment qui a changé ma vie c'est
pendant que j'étais en train de patauger
dans des études et des bouleaux divers
et variés et pas très intéressant à
changer un copain qui me montre à une
telle une offre de l'ac thann 2 days and
fall qui est donc un de ses seuls
spectacle capté et l'âge et il ya
vraiment un truc qui brille dans mon
cerveau et je me rends compte ça aligne
les planètes en moi je me rends compte
que plein de choses que j'aimais déjà et
que je faisais séparément écrire être
marrante être analytique et mehdi certes
et c'est tout à coup ça léger mais si
elle existe cette forme en fait c'est un
métier alors que c'était pas du tout un
projet chez moi à la base quand j'ai
vraiment ça a ouvert un champ des
possibles c'est ça qui est très
compliqué dans les métiers créatifs je
crois dans l'orientation en général
c'est très compliqué de passer de jeu
fini le collège où je suis bacheliers et
j'ai choisi un métier parce que entre le
fantasme que tu t'en fais les stages
éventuellement qui veulent rien dire les
études qui sont pas forcément comme la
réalité du boulot c'est très difficile
d'aligner tout ça est et dans les
métiers créatifs encore pire parce que
tu dis vraiment la personne que tu vois
sous les spotlights maquiller qui a
répété et après ce danseur d'air tu ne
vois pas quelles sont toutes les petites
étapes aura d'autres et moi j'ai de la
chance que tout à coup la forme clic ça
que je me dis [ __ ] ça c'est un job
mais à plein de gens qu'ils pourraient
faire plein de tout bien qu'ils se
rendent même pas compte que c'est un taf
en fait je pensais ce serait intéressant
d'essayer de créer deux des meilleurs
pont d'orientation jusqu'à beaucoup de
gens qui se perdent entre 15 et 30 ans
et qui finissent par faire le boulot
qu'ils aiment pas trop parce qu'il faut
payer les factures et c'est normal
parce que t'as pas de chemin nette entre
ton point de départ et l'arrivée